cancelled cameos deleted droids and
headless humanoids are just some of the
things that didn't make the final cut of
row Guan in this video I'm going to
break down the movies deleted scenes and
characters and examine the reshoots and
rumors and what they meant for the film
there are also some really interesting
rejected concepts which I'll be looking
at too of course there are spoilers
ahead for rogue 1 and anything Star Wars
related so be aware of that and if
you're not ready make sure you see the
movie first and check out my spoiler
free review by tapping up here when
Industrial Light and Magic Steve
creative officer John Knoll pitched his
original rogue Wong concept he put
forward a lineup of characters that was
vastly different to the final team we
see in the movie the original title was
going to be destroyer of worlds and as
well as humans the rebel crew included
two alien characters called Luna and
Senna Luna and Senna went through
multiple versions of design during
development with Senna initially
depicted as a Chewbacca style alien and
Luna as a kind of sidekick who could
skitter into an air duct almost like a
little thief the aliens were later
replaced with the duo Charis in way and
Bay's Melba's although later designs of
Senna appear to be the basis for the
mercenary more off who fights with saw
Guerrero's partisans the other original
rogue one team members were jyn erso
k to so3 nevus reah Tala and Jairus
Kestrel also during this early concept
period cranek was actually an imperial
spy who had infiltrated the team sending
back his intelligence to an imperial
officer Cole will excrete as well as
changing many original characters the
concept for rogue one change from an
ensemble action movie to one with more
emphasis on Djinn as a central character
however it seems that by the final cut
of the movie Jin's role and screen time
were perd back somewhat the trailers
point to these cuts with various
exchanges between jinn general Draven
and Mon Mothma
deleted from the final movie including
Mon Mothma slide on your own from the
age of 15 reckless aggressive and
undisciplined and there are also some
snippets of snarky dialogue from the
trailers that were cut from the final
film one of which was Jin's line I rebel
the words proved unpopular with some
fans who felt the dialogue was a bit too
on-the-nose and it's been rumored that
one objective of the reshoots was to
make Jin's character
less antagonistic kita gins partially
missing backstories what appear to be
some significant deleted scenes with
sauger era in the celebration sizzle
reel there's a deleted scene where Jin
and Sora outside
notice that Sora's board at this point
like he is at the start of the movie
when he rescues a young Jin
rather than gray herd as the years when
gym meets him in his cave in the final
movie which suggests that his cutscene
has set a few years before the main
timeline of rogue one we know that
soroban dungeon when she was 16 as he
feared for her safety among his fellow
partisans so could this shots be showing
that very moment when he left her which
they talk about in the movie the first
trailer also shows a deleted scene with
the board saga Raritan features a speech
he gives to Jin what will you do
wouldn't it catch you what will you do
if they break you if you continue to
fight what will you become and it seems
like these words that we never hear in
the final movie and which may imply that
Jin was fighting alongside saw may have
given further background - I saw
abandoned Jin when she was a teenager
remember that saga era was considered an
extremist with the Rebel Alliance
cutting ties with him so perhaps the
idea for cutting out this part of Jin's
backstory was to make her a more
sympathetic character rumors have also
surfaced of a deleted scene between
soccer era and Darth Vader the rumor
claims there is a scene where Vader
attacks or badly injuring the rebel
fighter and it's also claimed that there
is another cutscene where Vader smashes
a Jedi Temple
both these claims are currently
unsubstantiated but if true they hint
towards a darker and even more violent
Vader than the one we already saw in
rogue one there are some Darth Vader
scenes from the trailers though that
were definitely cut from the final movie
there's a cool shot of Vader looking
honor to read schematic of possibly the
Death Star plans another foreboding
reflection of his image set against a
fiery red planet or star and there's a
cutscene where cranek tells Vader the
power we are dealing with here is
immeasurable what we see in the
background of these scenes as well as an
officially released promo still suggests
that before the reshoots Vader might
also have appeared on the Death Star in
addition to Mustafar by the way there
are also rumors of a deleted scene where
Darth Vader hunted down three of the
main characters and killed them and I
wonder
this shot of a TIE fighter appearing at
the top of the antenna tower could have
been Vader arriving to take out Jin
Cassian and chronic person name the
scenes on scarify certainly a part of
the movie where we can see numerous
scenes were cut from the trailers which
suggests that there was some significant
reworking of the story in the third act
for example the transmission of the data
tapes to the Rebel Alliance appears to
have been rework substantially the first
trailer has Jean and her crew running
through the Citadel carrying the data
tapes and in another shot they're
dodging enemy fire from storm troopers
and a TAC TS on the beach while carrying
the tapes remember in the final cut of
the movie k2 Esso dives inside the
Citadel while Jin and Cassie are
recovering the tape but in this shot
from the celebration sizzle it looks
like alan tudyk who played k2 Esso is
running along the beach in the
background in his mocap suit so it could
be that originally the snarky droid
didn't die or at least not in the way we
saw in the movie these cutscenes could
also suggest that the team was going to
physically deliver the plans initially
rather than transmit the virus satellite
link or perhaps more likely the
transmission antenna was located in a
different position to the Citadel
whether recover the tapes in the final
movie which meant that the team had to
run across the beach to reach the tower
by the way notice how Jin and Caspian
have their normal clothes on at this
point rather than their Imperial
disguises which seems to add to the
theory that much of the assault on scarf
was reworked during reshoots other
deleted scenes and thus Gareth battle
includes storm troopers marching through
the water
critics badass scene where he lands and
walk through the water training his
white cloak behind him and this done the
space monkeys scene were his
machine-gunning from the inside of a
rebel ship seems to have been cut back
as well another casualty of the reshoots
was astromech Imperial droids c2b 5 who
served in the Citadel vaults performing
maintenance tasks CTB 5 also dubbed as
evil r2d2 by fans when the character was
officially announced didn't get any
significant screen time but had a
blinking you're miss it cameos scooting
behind some stormtroopers in the Citadel
I wonder if they ever had in mind with
this character to play on how the Death
Star plans are interested to r2d2
reversing that or mirroring it in some
way although all the characters die at
the end of row one in the very first
screenplay they actually didn't in fact
director Gareth Edwards says he kept
expecting to be asked to pose in a sea
we're gin and casseon survived and are
living on another planet
however edy was added that new kiss film
and Disney understood that because the
characters weren't in a new hope it made
sense that they shouldn't survive rogue
one as long as providing the motion
capture and voice but Kate Oso Alan
Tudyk also filmed a small live-action
cameo as an Imperial pilot the pilot
would have been credited as played by
Rainier Lee who is the actors character
in the webseries con man however the
scene was curt which to dicuss joked is
entirely appropriate whose character in
conman
by the way Kate Oso also had a joke cut
from the trailers where he goes up to
Jin and declares the captain says you
are a friend I will not kill you there's
an intriguing deleted cameo in rogue one
by model and actress Eunice Illuma de
who filmed a scene on Jeddah as a
rebellion leader where she runs through
a bar chased by tank and stormtroopers
in the scene she's wearing what she's
described as a really outlandish costume
and a sort of mushroom on her head and
there's been speculation there her
character might have been ahsoka tano
who's featured in both the animated Star
Wars TV shows the Clone Wars and rebels
Han Solo directors Phil Lord and Chris
Miller almost made it into Row one with
cameos and scenes were meant to be part
of the Jedi sequence however due to
timing conflicts they weren't able to
attend the shoot of course Star Wars
fans can't forget layers famous
nerf-herder insult to Han Solo in the
Empire Strikes Back and it looks like
the original script 401 plan to
introduce actual nerf herders for the
first time in the Star Wars movies sadly
they didn't make it to the big screen
but they were likely going to appear on
II do concept art for the movie also
reveals numerous deleted characters and
locations from rogue one on jeddah there
was storm troopers that rode these
incredibly tall camel like animals and
chronic even had a novice set upon Jada
in early concept art also the some
emitted backstory and characters that
would have explained what fugitive
surgeon Cornelius Eva's arm was doing on
jeder
the headless humanoid kaizen bog was
hinted at in the trailers but we didn't
get to see the strange-looking servants
called the de Crane eiated whoever Zhang
created during his various operations on
jeder
Sora also had a medical droid called g21
b7 which he used to help keep himself
alive and there were Imperial droids
scurrying around the core tower in the
Scarab Citadel that would have
cause problems for gin trying to access
the data tapes and there was going to be
a mountain planet where the inner Death
Star dish was hidden the dish would have
risen out of a lake on the planet to
attach itself to the Death Star but the
whole concept was scrapped for being too
complicated
and there was a bunch of other stuff
from the trailers that didn't make it in
as well take a look at some of it here
and if you have any theories on what it
means let me know below on jeder there
are a group of rebel pilots who've been
taken prisoner and are being marched
along by storm troopers and in another
shot gin handsome think to the little
girl who she later saves during the
partisan attack on the storm troopers
there's a scene with gin sitting in the
front of casseon ship a hologram of the
Death Star that pops up at the rebel
base on Yavin 4 and finally we never got
to see this very cool iconic shot of gin
and her Imperial combat suit so guys
what do you think about the deleted
scenes and reshoots
are there any deleted characters you'd
like to have been in the movie I'd love
to hear thoughts in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
to like share subscribe and turn on your
notifications to make sure you get all
my new videos as soon as they're ready
in the meantime you can check out more
of my videos right here thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers